cette maman laure 10 ans et reprises je
vous rappelle que nous les gens
aujourd'hui yves mourousi qui est accusé
de violation de domicile car ils entrent
de force chez les gens qui ne l'ont pas
forcément invité ce par le biais du
petit écran et qu'il est également
accusée d' occupation illégale de
plantation et plus précisément de
bananier car lorsque le régime tombe
il trouve le moyen de rester dans
l'arbre voilà effectivement il s'agit là
d'une inculpation grave alors qu'ils
tombent sous le coup de la loi et c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs la société en colère
a chargé son porte parole de transmettre
ce courroux de la société française
contre l'accusé par l'organe au combien
puis sein du procureur général de la
république des proches française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
françaises français belges belle mon
président mon chien un bleu raclures du
barreau de mes deux chaises
ta gueule rien chers téléspectateurs du
journal télévisé de 13 heures mon 13h
jeu douteux oui c'est léger mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri mon
amour en contrant tout à l'heure aux
marches du palais l'une de mes pairs le
l'un de mes pairs tu me les coupera
rencontres en rencontres en tout à
l'heure aux marches du palais l'un de
mes pairs le procureur jean baptiste
vaquette de gribeauval je lui faisais
part de ma joie bien légitime à l'idée
de salir publiquement yves mourousi à
l'audience d'aujourd'hui qui donc
avez-vous dit sans qui cet homme
mourousi plait-il élus morose et je prie
de m'excuser mais c'est la première fois
que j'entends prononcer ce nom
enfin tout de même il morosi la télé 1
division pour 20 me je n'ai pas la
télévision et c'est parce que celle
division je regarde jamais division
comme on peut tout regarder la
télévision je vais au cinéma mois maire
de croix et oui c'est l'un des snow
bismes les plus courus depuis une
décennie il consiste à ne pas regarder
la télévision ou ce qui revient au même
à faire croire qu'on la regarde jamais
l'important est de ne pas faire comme le
peuple en 1952 où 53 les nantis de la
culture cultivait le snobisme inverse
qui donc juger vous aujourd'hui charlie
chaplin plaide-t-il
charlie chaplin charlie chaplin je vous
prie de m'excuser sur première fois
enfin tout de même chaplin charlot le
cinoche au cinéma mais mon pauvre ami je
vais pas au cinéma je sais pas ce que
c'est cinéma je vais jamais au cinéma
comment peut-on aller au cinéma j'ai
l'atv mois mais en quoi dieu est
peut-être éternel mesdames et messieurs
les jurés mais pas autant que la
connerie humaine
c'est ainsi que chaque époque a ses snob
et c'est snobisme au milieu du xvième
siècle sentant s'entend après gutenberg
quand le livre imprimé a commencé à
descendre vraiment dans la rue vous
savez ce qu'ils disent est l'ancêtre de
mon procureur bruce nash r1 les livres
audio monsieur jeunes de savoie point
qu'il existe wade livre donc ne
possédera le moindre mot logiquement
peut-on lire ce que je suis lié en moi
monsieur je me fais sauter par henri iii
mais en quoi je précise que les vagues
et de gribeauval descendant en droite
ligne des bourbons qui sont tous un peu
tard et depuis ce jour sont de trés 128
ou charles iii le connétable se fit
déposséder par sa branche cadette d'un
prix bien je le précise à l'attention de
l'avocat le plus badinter qui somnole à
présent sous nos yeux en digérant
bruyamment la morue melba que sa tata
rodriguez lui envoyer de lisbonne enfin
kiev à dos
je paie je précise que quand je dis que
charles iii le connétable s'est fait
déposséder par sa branche cadette
je ne suggérerai évidemment pas qu'il
avait eu des relations intimes avec un
bâton
oui non mais je suis de votre avis on va
quand même pas faire toutes les missions
sur henry droit alors que si ça se
trouve à ragots et l écoute s'il ya
alors s'il ya des auditeurs dans la
salle qui ne voit pas le rapport entre
aragon et henri iii qu ils nous écrivent
ils ont gagné un bilboquet attend donc
les bourbons sont des cons bien que bien
que comme le dit si judicieusement le
comte de paris quand il est bourré pour
un vrai noble de france il vaut mieux
descendre des bourbons que des whiskys
mais mais mais revenons-en à yves
mourousi avant qu'il ne s'en aille et
que réparé la consternante bassesse des
propos échangés dans ce tribunal en
parlant de snobs je ne visais pas yves
mon lapin encore comme dit que vous
fricoter volontiers nuitamment avec les
boursouflé du tout-paris à le tout-paris
navrante baudruche pailleté des nuits
parisiennes triste gratin trop cuite
pauvre pantin nocturne qui vous forcer à
ne pas vous coucher pour reculer au
maximum cette heure tragique de vérité
où la vedette adulée se retrouve face à
sa solitude
pathétique et désolé les yeux sur le
menton et le caleçon sur les genoux
un morne kaka matinale j'allais dire que
vous étiez prêt je sais j'ai tort
j'attends de le prendre sur ce ton toute
façon je ne sais même pas de quoi je
parle je ne veux je ne vais jamais
l'elysée matignon
je ne sais pas qui castel moi me suit
mais comment peut-on aller chérif line
mais je dîne chez claude villers mais
merde quoi bon vous êtes toujours
l'amour bonjour
yat il y at il parmi la demi-douzaine de
jurés qui rumine à nos pieds quelqu'un
qui s'intéressent de près ou de loin aux
chefs d'accusation retenus contre
l'accusé
vous les sortez d'où mon président c'est
la t2c des prétoires qui vous a mordu ou
quoi vous attendait peut-être le retour
de 6/4 à mon avis c'est pas de mal avec
papy montant en aura marre de chanter
les feuilles mortes avant qu'il revienne
le valley fois peut-être que j'arrête un
peu et qu'il monte en sinon il va pas
vouloir venir sur guillotiné chez nous
un type extraordinaire yves montand
avant il chantait comme carlos il
faisait pouet pouet en gigotant dans
tous les sens et puis un jour sa femme
l'a dit qu'il était intelligent bain
depuis le croit
bah
n'empêche qu'il montant c'est la seule
personne en france à part mon coiffeur
qui possède les clefs du drame polonais
c'est vrai à cette différence près que
mon coiffeur il en cause pas dans le
poste comme il dirigera ce pas gratis
mme bon alors pour finir les chefs
d'accusation c'est très léger c'est très
léger je n'entretiendrai qu'un
violations plantations alors comme ça
monsieur mourousi vous squattez risée
les bananiers et comme le régime tombe
vous restez dans l'arbre vous attendait
peut-être que mitterrand créé pour vous
un ministère des bananes étrangères
alors que vous n'êtes pas le seul à
avoir ce goût de l'exotisme jean auroux
l'ancien chef scout qui féminise du
travail lui aussi résiste difficilement
aux sirènes de l'exotisme hier soir chez
elle et dînette lui j'adore dîner avec
des socialistes pendant qu'ils bouffent
ils disent pas des conneries
or on m'avait amené dans un restaurant
tahitien très très particulier on y
mange les noix de coco couché sur une
natte à même le sol
ah je sais bien ça paraît inimaginable à
ministre du travail français à plat
ventre devant des cocos et ben said donc
y mozy coupable à ça mais je demanderai
tout mais mesdames et messieurs les
jurés de le punir par où il a péché
c'est à dire par là non pas par là par
là quoi qu'il en soit je demanderai au
jury d'être indulgent avec yves mourousi
auquel la cour reconnaît une
circonstance vachement atteignant il est
dernier au hit parade des présentateurs
de télévision organisé auprès de ses
lecteurs par le parisien libéré le
premier étant le sympathique jean claude
bourret le célèbre fruits naturels d'une
liaison contre nature entre soeur
sourire et la vache qui rit aussi bien
je lui il se coupe aussi bien je vous le
dis il vous y allez en paix car
quelqu'un qui déplaît aux lecteurs du
parisien libéré ne peut pas être tout à
fait mauvais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
etonnant non